hey everyone this is steve weintraub
with collider and i am absolutely and i
want to say this absolutely thrilled to
have the people on my right here in the
collider studio uh for sandman
obviously um no introduction
no introduction i'm not going to say it
i'm just saying sandman we all know we
we see um i want to start with i've seen
the first three episodes and
your
who reads collider and is watching this
interview knows who this man is there's
no introduction needed um i've seen the
first three episodes and they're so good
and i i have to start with you like
sandman has been in development as a
movie as something for a very long time
and i'm so happy it wasn't a movie
because it would have sucked like
straight up and tv streaming is like the
perfect location can you sort of talk
about how this is the best place for
this material absolutely i mean so for
years people were trying to make sandman
movies
and they would try and take 3 000 pages
of story
and tell it in two hours which is an
awful lot like trying to take a river
and put it in a pint glass and they
would fail
um
and i
was nothing to do with these although
there was at least one script that was
so bad that i sent it to people on the
internet who then did an article about
how bad it was which killed that
particular version um
but i
was basically a long way away from all
of these
and in around 2018
as the nature of television changed and
i was
show running good omens
which i'd written david goyer got in
touch with me and said it's time
for
sandman it's time to do this together as
a
streamer i think we can do it and we can
do it right and uh are you on board i
said
i'm
he and he was saying this is the first
time you've been invited on as a
creative person
would you do it with me and i said yeah
and then
he had to wait until i finished making
good omens and
we were also very lucky because as i
finished making good omens alan
heinberg's contract
expired and he came free and available
and we had dinner with him david and i
and
he turned out to be a rabid sandman fan
who had a page of sandman that he had
bought in 1996 and had me sign and i
and we all sat there and we talked about
the show we wanted to make and it became
very clear we were all talking about the
same show we all the three of us all had
the same vision for what we wanted to
make and what this thing could be
which meant that
the most amazing
special effects or miracle to do with
sandman
happened and over that weekend
alan heinberg's contract was agreed and
signed that's amazing and monday morning
we pitched
sandman
to a bunch of streamers and networks
who pitched themselves to us
and
a week later netflix had won an exciting
bidding war
but what they had won was the idea that
warner brothers television
and
david and alan and i would make the
sandman show that we wanted to make
so it wasn't like
they
bought this thing and now we're going to
cut it up and change it and cook it and
stuff it was like no they bought the
right to make the thing we wanted to do
and um
that
we have made especially alan
um who's just done so much of the heavy
lifting i i get to take so much of the
glory because mostly i just leaned over
his shoulder and went yeah that's a good
idea um but
we got to make sandman we got this
unbelievably awesome cast and they are
merely the tip of the awesome cast
iceberg
and
we
you know august the 5th we dropped 10
episodes season one
it's
it's amazing i'm so proud of it and it
couldn't have been made at any other
time
there for the cast i definitely want to
know uh listen there's a lot of stuff in
the episodes that's awesome but what are
you really what are you most excited for
audiences to see that are both fans and
non-fans
i think it's just that
it's such an epic journey
it defies genre there are so many genres
within it and each one is really
resolved it's really fulfilled so you
feel like you're entering
truly another dimension and one that has
been gone about with such integrity
incredible creativity and genuine love
and and deep respect for the material
it's just a
phantom asgorical adventure
yeah and while it is a cohesive story i
feel like each episode is like a film
and it's a new film every time that you
switch to the next one and i think
that's a kind of thrilling way to
experience a story and unusual in
streaming um
i but then also i want the audience to
see these specific worlds the dreaming
is one of the most extraordinary places
that i've ever
born witness to on a screen it's
narnia and middle earth and hogwarts
times by the breadth of imagination of a
universe and
there's hell and there's that the
the contemporary world which is a new
thing like
the world of 2021 this isn't a period
piece sandman was birthed in 1989 but we
have made it in the present day and it's
exciting for
for the people who know the comics so
well to see these characters
have to face up to the realities of the
modern world
i'm just really really excited for
people who are massive fans of it to
kind of see the things come to life
themselves because you know when i my
experience of watching it i all it did
was bring me back to you know flipping
through the pages when i was first
reading it to begin with and i was like
it's you know it's a very i don't know
it's an emotional experience if you are
in
love with the original text which i am
yeah
i'm super excited both for the fans and
also people who are just discovering the
sandman and who maybe just stumble upon
it because they trust netflix and
netflix is such a trusted entity uh i
think it's
really incredible uh like tom said i
mean each episode it sort of like
cleanses your palette like each one is
so different they are like standalone
short films and the casts change and the
way their shot changes and the locations
and
it is obviously it's fantastical and it
is it is a fantasy it is this epic
journey but also i mean i look at our
episode and we spent the almost the
entire thing walking and talking in
london in a what is a very what could be
just a very
sort of it's a regular setting right
we're like we're not anywhere that that
is necessarily like in someone's
imagination like the dreaming or
something like that but even that has
its own
fantastical feel it feels like this
utopia even though we are literally
20 21 on earth walking around and i
think that there is a magic to every
single part of the show whether that be
actual magic or even just the magic in
the mundane and i think that that is
what i'm really really excited about
because i think it's going to be unlike
anything anyone's ever seen before i
don't want to do any spoilers but i do
want to ask this for all of you it's 10
episodes which is your
which is your favorite episode of the 10
or which are you most excited for
audiences to see of the 10
i want them to see episode
six after they've experienced episode
five
because it's a wonderful way
it's like
episode four takes them to hell in a
good way episode five puts them through
hell
in a diner
episode six is
cleansing and forgiving and embracing
and warming and beautiful
but you have to earn it yeah
no absolutely it's interesting because
it's uh like
the episode i'm most excited for is is
the episode in hell because when i
watched that i was just
it was one of the most stunning things
i've ever seen and uh talk about taking
ideas that are so
familiar like satan and
presenting it in a way that no one has
ever seen before and i've read the
comics and still felt like i'd never
seen this character before um but i do
think what you're saying i mean there is
this ebb and flow to the and you are you
are earning things you are you you have
to build some points to get to where
where you need to get to on this show
and that is that's rare it's rare that
you um give the audience a chance to
learn things
you know to learn and to appreciate and
to digest
i am i sat down to watch the episodes
really
not knowing what to expect because what
i'd done was in such isolation and and
only with tom
and then
from them
literally from the minute it started
i
gasped
and then
i just was
just so connected to it and so
fascinated to and it it takes a lot to
watch something and it genuinely takes
your breath away i was also watching it
with my partner who kept saying this is
really good this is no this is really
good
this is so good i was like yeah i know
can we just watch it and he said but
it's so good
yeah i know darling but please oh do you
know what you're right it's good let's
just say it's good because it's really
good
i mean i agree with everything everybody
said so i'll try and think of something
new um
there are two things i want to say one
uh is
is within episode six but not with my
sister
is um
morpheus's relationship with hobgatling
um uh
potentially his
first
friendship on earth
um
uh and it's a relationship that's built
over
hundreds of years um
and i think there's something very
exciting about watching these two
characters grow together from the 14th
century to the present day um and very
unusual and then i think also the
culmination of the story we're telling
the final confrontation between morpheus
and the corinthian
and i'm excited for an audience to have
lived
the experience that we're going to give
them and to come to its conclusion
i mean easy answer for me i think
episode five is is just so special it's
that delight
i need to listen i have a million other
questions but i have to stop i'm just
gonna say for everyone watching all 10
episodes of the sandman will be on
netflix on august 5th
i cannot wait to finish the series thank
you so much for coming in and i hope you
have a great comic-con thank you for
having me
you